Traduttore: Giulia Donzelli
Revisore: Maria Pericleous
Io non guardavo mai la tv,
Ho vissuto molti anni all'estero,
e quindi non potevo
guardare la tv italiana.
Però, tutte le volte che tornavo in Italia
facevo un gesto semplicissimo:
accendevo la televisione.
E quello che vedevo mi stupiva.
Primo punto che vi chiedo
di tenere a mente.
Vedevo cose che non vediamo
negli altri paesi europei,
almeno non in questa quantità.
Guardavo e mi domandavo
- e, come ho sempre fatto fin da bambina,
di fronte a delle cose che non funzionano,
avevo voglia di reagire.
Quindi telefonavo agli amici
che vivevano in Italia
perché pensavo di aver colto
qualcosa che non funzionava,
ma solo in quel momento.
"Marco?!" - un amico -
"Marco, sono davanti alla televisione,
sono le sei del pomeriggio,
ci sono bambini e bambine davanti,
c'è una ragazza sotto il tavolo
come se fosse le gambe del tavolo".
E la risposta era:
"Ma Lorella, scusa,
questa è la televisione"
Ah. Tornavo all'estero.
Dopo qualche mese tornavo.
Accendevo la TV.
"Mamma?! Mamma scusa,
accendi la televisione,
sto vedendo una cosa pazzesca,
credo di aver beccato un'immagine
che non può andare in onda,
sono le sei del pomeriggio.
C'è una ragazza
appesa come un prosciutto,
come in un campo di concentramento,
con il sedere scoperto,
quasi nuda, e tutti ridono.
Telefoniamo alla trasmissione!"
E mia madre rispondeva:
"Ma è la TV".
La stessa risposta
che mi aveva dato Marco,
che aveva un'altra età, un'altra cultura,
un altro ambiente e un altro mondo.
Quindi mi accorgevo
che mentre ero stata via,
la televisione era diventata quella cosa
che vedevo quando tornavo.
E pensavo, ma in quante famiglie arriva?
Quante persone sta influenzando?
Quante ragazze e ragazzi?
Quanti bambini e bambine?
Ma non vedevo una reazione,
e mi chiedevo come mai.
Quindi ho avuto voglia di fare qualcosa.
Non era esattamente il mio mestiere,
ma volevo arrivare
ai ragazzi e alle ragazze italiane.
Ho detto: come ci arrivo?
Un libro?
Si ma, un libro poi i ragazzi
e le ragazze non lo leggono.
Un video!
Ok, proviamo a fare un video.
Quindi ho chiesto a degli amici
che lavoravano in questo campo.
Ho detto, facciamo un video
da mettere online - quindi breve -
che arrivi a ragazzi e ragazze.
Obiettivo: innalzare il livello
di consapevolezza,
dire: non è cosi da tutte le altre parti,
e la tv può anche fare bene
non per forza fare male.
Può rappresentarci bene,
non per forza
rappresentarci male.
Ci sono degli esempi.
Ci siamo messi insieme ad altri due amici,
Marco Malfi e Cesare Cantù,
e abbiamo visto, in poche settimane,
400 ore di intrattenimento televisivo.
Ci siamo focalizzati
sull'intrattenimento,
e da quello abbiamo ricavato
20 minuti di un video
che abbiamo deciso poi
di mettere online.
Oggi non possiamo vederne
tutti i 20 minuti,
ne vediamo 3 minuti,
uno spezzone.
[Dal video]
Ricordo quando Marco mi diceva
che la tv ha un potere incredibile:
pur parlando del reale,
rappresentando il reale,
riesce a dissimulare.
La TV oggi ruba, deturpa,
mina il paesaggio
della coscienza di tutti.
Ci toglie le radici e le fondamenta.
Volti ricondotti a maschere
della chirurgia estetica,
corpi gonfiati a dismisura,
come fenomeni da baraccone
di un circo perenne
che ci rimanda a un idea di donna
contraffatta e irreale.
Allora, sono sicura che la TV,
la puoi guardare, la puoi sopportare
ma solo pensando che è un grande circo.
Chi siamo?
Cosa vogliamo?
Come mai tutte le donne d'Italia
non scendono in piazza
protestando per come
veniamo rappresentate?
[musica]
IL CORPO DELLE DONNE
WOMEN'S BODIES
by Lorella Zanardo and
Marco Malfi Chindemi
Dei 45 muscoli facciali
a parte quelli necessari per masticare,
baciare, odorare, soffiare,
tutti gli altri servono per
esprimere emozioni.
Più articolato e complesso
sarà il carattere
- intendendo per carattere
la nostra essenza più profonda -
più individuale sarà
l'espressione del volto.
Cosa stanno nascondendo questi volti?
Perché le donne non possono più apparire
con la loro vera faccia in TV?
Perché non c'è più nessuna donna adulta
che possa mostrare il suo volto?
Perché questa umiliazione?
Dobbiamo avere vergogna
di mostrare la nostra faccia?
Dover nascondere le nostre rughe:
il passaggio del tempo
che lascia le sue tracce sul nostro volto
è dunque una vergogna?
Ennesimo sopruso a cui
nessun uomo viene obbligato.
Diceva Anna Magnani al truccatore
che prima del ciak stava per coprirle
le rughe del volto:
"Lasciamele tutte,
non me ne togliere nemmeno una,
ci ho messo una vita a farmele."
[musica]
Perché non reagiamo?
Perché non ci presentiamo
nella nostra verità?
Perché accettiamo questa
umiliazione continua?
Perché non ci occupiamo
dei nostri diritti?
Di che cosa abbiamo paura?
(Applausi)
Abbiamo messo questo video
online 4 anni fa,
non abbiamo investito un euro
in campagne stampa,
non abbiamo un agente che ci rappresenti.
Dal giorno dopo è stata un esplosione.
Avevamo un blog, "Il corpo delle donne",
[con] migliaia di persone
che ci scrivevano.
Il tema conduttore
e la cosa più comune
che ci scrivevano era:
"Pensavo la stessa cosa
ma non avevo le parole per dirlo".
Perché questa attenzione che abbiamo
da 4 anni sulla televisione?
Molti ci dicono:
"Ma Zanardo, adesso c'è Internet".
Perché questa attenzione
per la televisione?
Allora, andiamo a vedere
un pochino i dati.
Se io chiedessi, per esempio,
a questa platea,
se volete rispondermi:
chi di voi non ha la TV?
Ok, io vi vedo da qua,
non so dirvi in percentuale
ma un 2-3% della platea.
Chi ne ha una?
OK, grazie.
Chi ne ha due?
OK
Chi ne ha tre?
Chi ne ha quattro?
OK.
Allora, quando andiamo
in giro per l'Italia
- da qui, cosa vi posso dire?
Chi non ne ha è un 2-3%, no?
Chi ne ha una e chi ne ha due
era la maggioranza.
Quando andiamo in giro per l'Italia
questo è il dato più ricorrente.
Cosa ci dicono i dati?
L'utenza complessiva, il 98%
delle persone, ha la TV.
Che cosa vuol dire?
La TV continua a essere un mezzo
visto dagli italiani e dalle italiane:
tutti, o quasi tutti,
ne abbiamo una o due...
al Sud quando facciamo questa domanda,
da Roma in giù spesso tre o quattro.
Il Sud è alto consumante,
si dice in gergo, di TV generalista.
Perché ci tengo a dire questo?
Stiamo capendo, qui oggi insieme,
che la TV continua a essere
il maggiore mezzo di informazione
per gli italiani e le italiane.
Lo dico perché l'altra sorpresa
che abbiamo avuto da quando
è uscito il documentario
è che c'erano persone - poche,
ma le persone che hanno
una grande influenza
che sono le persone
che dirigono i giornali,
gli intellettuali,
i professori universitari
che alzavano la mano
nei nostri dibattiti e dicevano:
"Zanardo, però la TV
basta non guardarla"
Non è così semplice.
"Basta non guardarla" per noi,
che scegliamo oggi di essere qui
a sentire una cosa bella.
Ma gli italiani e le italiane
guardano, invece, la TV.
Perché?
Perché siamo scarsi lettori di quotidiani,
- ecco perché è importante
correlare i dati -
e perché c'è anche un altro dato:
se noi confrontiamo i dati
di quanta gente guarda la TV in Italia,
è lo stesso numero di persone
che troviamo in Inghilterra.
In Inghilterra abbiamo
lo stesso numero di utenti TV;
ma gli inglesi, poi,
leggono tanti quotidiani.
Voi potete dirmi:
"Zanardo, orrendi, il "Sun"":
certo, ma lo leggono.
Vanno a teatro:
a vedere anche spettacoli
miseri, ma ci vanno.
Leggono libri:
brutti, ma li leggono.
Quindi le informazioni agli inglesi
vengono da diversi canali.
Agli italiani e alle italiane
principalmente vengono dalla televisione.
Incrociamo questo con un altro dato:
dati OCSE recentissimi,
abbiamo il tasso di abbandono scolastico
tra i più alti in Europa,
in particolare, in alcune
zone della Campania
c'è il tasso di abbandono scolastico
più alto d'Europa.
Guardate, questo è il dato più allarmante
che abbiamo sentito negli ultimi anni.
Perché è importante?
Quando cresciamo, ci sono
tre potenti agenti di socializzazione.
Poi se ne aggiunge un quarto da adulti,
che è il mondo del lavoro.
E sono la famiglia, la scuola, e la tv.
La famiglia:
stamattina, prima di venire qui,
mi ha chiamato una radio
mi ha detto: "Zanardo, cosa pensa
delle bambine che si prostituiscono?
È colpa delle madri?"
E la mia risposta è:
"I cittadini di un Paese democratico
non sono l'effetto di un caso,
ma sono il risultato
di un processo educativo".
Quindi, non voglio
deresponsabilizzare le famiglie,
- ricordando che però
ci sono anche i padri -
ma vorrei puntare il dito su una cosa:
dobbiamo assolutamente potenziare
gli altri due agenti di socializzazione,
che sono la scuola, che viene
perennemente depauperata negli ultimi anni
e tornare ad avere un servizio pubblico
degno di questo nome,
perché attraverso la TV
possiamo fare dei cambiamenti epocali.
Dico solo velocemente
che negli anni '60 c'era una trasmissione
- lo dico per i più giovani
e le più giovani -
che si chiamava "Non è mai troppo tardi".
Se lo dite adesso,
qualche intellettuale storce il naso
e dice "Ma vogliamo
rivolgerci al passato?"
No.
Ma in quegli anni venivano
persino dal Giappone
a imparare come si faceva
buona televisione in Italia.
Attraverso quella trasmissione,
un milione e mezzo di italiani
prese la licenza elementare.
Tornare a fare buona TV,
impossessarsi almeno
di un canale televisivo,
vuol dire cambiare le sorti del paese.
C'è anche un tasso altissimo
di analfabetismo funzionale.
Vuol dire che non siamo
più illetterati,
nel senso che sappiamo leggere e scrivere,
ma a stento, capiamo dei ragionamenti
che siano anche solo
un pochino complicati.
C'è un dato che non tutti conoscono,
ma è importante.
Siamo migliorati un po',
ma nel Global Gender Gap Report,
che viene stilato
dal World Economic Forum,
l'Italia è al settantesimo posto.
È un indice che misura
la differenza che c'è tra i sessi.
Badate che tutti i paesi europei
sono tra i primi 20.
È un dato di cui in Italia si parla poco:
in Aprile ho passato una settimana
per conoscere il sistema
delle pari opportunità in Svezia,
e il primo Ministero con cui
mi hanno fatto incontrare
è stato il Ministero dell'economia.
E ho chiesto: "Come mai?
Perché non mi fate incontrare
il Ministero delle Pari Opportunità?"
E il Ministro mi ha detto:
"Perché noi, passando dal
quinto posto al quarto posto,
e quindi dando più
occupazione alle donne,
e di conseguenza più asili nido
per permettere di lavorare,
miglioriamo il PIL".
Quindi è un dato estremamente importante
quello di cui stiamo parlando.
È una rappresentazione
che aiuti le bambine
- ma anche i bambini
vedremo in ultima analisi -
a, come direbbero gli inglesi,
essere "empowered",
a non vedersi rappresentati
sempre e solo come oggetti.
Da ultimo, siamo a Como,
che è in Lombardia,
che è in Italia, ma che è in Europa.
Per chi di voi viaggia o ha
a che fare con i paesi europei,
sappiamo che l'immagine
che abbiamo dato,
anche attraverso la nostra televisione,
non ha certo aiutato
l'immagine del nostro Paese,
e a ottenere la credibilità
che ci meritiamo.
C'è poco tempo
e vi voglio parlare
della cosa forse più bella
che è successa dopo questo documentario.
Le persone che ci hanno scritto di più,
alcune le ho viste, sono qui,
sono state le insegnanti
e gli insegnanti di tutta Italia.
Riceviamo da quattro anni,
al nostro semplicissimo blog,
ilcorpodelledonne.com,
e alla nostra pagina Facebook,
migliaia di richieste da tutta Italia,
E qui c'è un grido
- è strano che degli insegnanti
debbano scrivere a un blog -
e dicono:
"Dateci degli strumenti
di educazione ai media".
C'è un gap, tra noi - bravissime,
noi incontriamo insegnanti
che sono eroi ed eroine,
ma non sono più formati da anni.
"Quindi dateci degli strumenti
perché di fronte a noi
ci sono i nativi digitali,
che guardano tante immagini".
Quindi abbiamo strutturato
un corso, da 4 anni,
si chiama "Nuovi occhi per i media:
strumenti di educazione
all'immagine e ai media
per tutti e tutte".
Andiamo quindi nelle scuole,
da veri attivisti,
e non diciamo, non guardare la TV.
Perché in un Paese democratico
la TV è un diritto,
e le persone vogliono,
ed è giusto che guardino la TV.
Ma chiediamo una TV migliore,
e al contempo non consegniamo
un'altra generazione al nulla.
Quindi diamo strumenti,
cosa vuol dire?
Avviene lo stesso passaggio
che avviene quando impariamo a leggere:
attraverso la capacità
di leggere le parole,
potremo in futuro
agire la cittadinanza attiva,
saremo meno manipolabili.
La stessa cosa avviene con le immagini.
Non dire ai ragazzi:
"Non guardare la TV"
ma dire: "Guardala con occhi responsabili."
Facciamo un piccolo esperimento,
andiamo nelle scuole,
registriamo molto di quello
che viene mandato in onda,
e diciamo ai ragazzi:
"Cosa avete visto ieri?"
"Transformat" che è una trasmissione
che va in onda in fascia pre serale.
Benissimo, la guardiamo insieme
e poi chiediamo:
Avete notato qualcosa?
C'è qualcosa che vi disturba?
Sapresti dire come la
telecamera viene usata?
Mmm.. No.
Perfetto, lo rivediamo
con delle indicazioni.
[Presentatore] Allora presentiamo
i concorrenti, Francesca,
di questa puntata.
Ormai sei una valletta
a tutti gli effetti,
basta, non sei più la super ospite.
[Valletta] I concorrenti di questa sera:
iniziamo con Alessia,
che ha 18 anni e arriva da Putignano,
è una studentessa
ma è anche una ritrattista.
[Presentatore] Bene.
[Valletta] Complimenti!
[Presentazione della concorrente donna:
inquadratura panoramica dai piedi
a salire per mostrare il corpo.
Non le viene data la parola.]
[Presentatore] E poi?
[Valletta] Poi abbiamo Francesco,
che ha 27 anni, arriva da Bologna,
e mi incuriosisce questa cosa
perché è un barman...
[Presentazione del concorrente uomo:
zoom frontale mirato sul volto.]
[Valletta] ... gli piace molto
la macchina per cucire.
[Concorrente] Eh si, in effetti
io ho una grande passione per la moda,
e ho iniziato anche a cucire:
insomma, fa comodo.
[Presentatore] Hai sentito tutte
le tue curiosità?
[Valletta] Poi ti chiedo i vestitini.
[Gli viene data la parola per descrivere
un suo hobby e la sua capacità.]
[Presentatore] Chiamiamoli
vestitini, e poi?
[Valletta] Poi abbiamo la nostra
concorrente Francesca,
ha 19 anni, arriva
dalla provincia di Caserta,
in particolare da
Santa Maria Capua Vetere.
[Di nuovo la presentazione
di una concorrente donna
avviene con una inquadratura dal basso
utile a mostrare il corpo.]
[Valletta] Ho detto giusto?
[Concorrente] Si, giusto.
[Valletta] Perfetto!
Lei è una studentessa
e inoltre fa anche l'hostess.
[Le viene data la parola solo per
confermare i dubbi della Valletta.]
[Presentatore] Possiamo iniziare allora?
[Valletta] Iniziamo subito!!!
[Presentatore] Bene, vai in posizione.
[Zanardo] Allora, so che fa ridere:
però immaginatevi, in assenza
di altri agenti di socializzazione,
là dove le famiglie
non riescono più a tenere,
dove la scuola
non riesce più a tenere,
queste trasmissioni vanno in onda
da 30 anni e peggio,
[in] 5 reti su 6
e in tutti gli orari.
E creano dei modelli.
Quindi non interroghiamoci più da adulti,
quando poi leggiamo sui giornali
tutto questo, molto di questo,
- è comunque un mezzo stupendo
che potrebbe fare molto.
Andiamo in migliaia di scuole:
in alcune regioni,
come la Toscana e il Trentino,
sono partiti dei progetti
di formazione ai formatori,
e laddove siamo stati aiutati
finanziariamente,
in Toscana sono già 30.000
i ragazzini che hanno potuto seguire
- e le ragazzine - i corsi di
educazione all'immagine.
È un'emergenza,
le scuole lo vogliono.
Ultimamente abbiamo avuto
l'interessamento del Ministero:
speriamo di riuscirlo a fare,
perché senza soldi non si può fare nulla.
Finisco con delle notizie positive.
La stessa cosa che vi ho
raccontato della televisione,
accade nelle pubblicità.
Quindi l'immaginario intero dell'Italia
è caratterizzato da una profonda
oggettivizzazione:
delle donne, ma in ultima analisi
anche degli uomini.
Gli stessi marchi che in Italia usano
dei simboli sessuali,
all'estero usano degli altri simboli.
C'è uno yogurt che in Italia
usa dei simboli sessuali da 20 anni
[e] negli altri paesi d'Europa
usa le capre, le mucche, i prati verdi.
Quindi, perché da noi?
Perché questo crea dei modelli,
e quindi di conseguenza
le generazioni crescono.
È un modo di depotenziare,
è un modo di non rispettare
il terzo articolo della Costituzione
che oltre a dire che siamo tutti uguali,
recita che ognuno deve essere
messo in grado
di esprimere al meglio
il proprio potenziale di persona.
Quindi questo immaginario non ci aiuta.
Questa è la buona notizia:
il lavoro che abbiamo fatto noi
e tantissime altre attiviste
negli ultimi anni
ha fatto si che ci siano
migliaia di ragazzine
che i media non raccontano, ve lo dico io,
perché non ci sono solo le ragazzine
che vogliono fare le veline,
e comunque di quello è responsabilità
della mia generazione.
Migliaia di ragazzine,
che io chiamo "Le attiviste anonime",
e di ragazzini, un 30%
che ci segue è maschio,
che sta rendendo il Paese migliore.
Chiediamo ai media che lo raccontino.
Protestano civilmente,
scrivono, dedicano un'ora
tutti i giorni del loro tempo
- e sono migliaia -
a scrivere alla TV,
alle agenzie di pubblicità,
dicendo: "Quella pubblicità mi offende."
Firmato: Lorella Zanardo,
Giuseppina Rossi, Mariolina Bianchi.
Lo fanno da anni:
il 70% delle pubblicità che avete visto
sono state ritirate in questo modo.
Anche in Rai questa onda sta arrivando,
nonostante tutti i problemi che sappiamo.
Ci sono migliaia di giovani
che i media non raccontano,
e che stanno cambiando il Paese.
Ecco, io vi volevo lasciare con questo,
dicendo: sosteniamole!
Perché il patto generazionale
altrimenti rischia di interrompersi,
invece è una spirale
che ha il diritto di continuare.
[Applausi]